ma con queste lingue ti pago benvenuti a
grandissima richiesta tornano il
gameplay
oggi andremo a provare tre nuovi giochi
orari tv una mamma virtuale è vero un po
cattiva un altro è il bambino di scary
teacher tre plichi clown ora di ice
cream però è un clown ed è un po pauroso
dopo però trovo divertente alla fine del
video crive temi come t bone è stato il
vostro preferito di questi tre mete date
un punteggio da 1 a 10
ognuno di questi servizi lo faremo che
noi infatti l'invio abbiamo un gioco per
voi cliccate mi piace 4 e l'ultima cifra
del vostro mi piace quindi ad esempio se
il vostro ad esempio il mi piace numero
1500 l'ultima cifra il 5 quindi voi
siete il 5
oppure se il vostro il mi piace numero
19 l'ultima cifra il 9 quindi voi siete
il 9 quindi cliccate mi piace il numero
che vs è il vostro personaggio 3
scrivetemi commenti quale è ora
mettetevi comodi prendervi parte
iniziamo per il primo gioco la mamma
virtuale c'è scritto che manchi ai tuoi
amici quindi vai a giocare con loro
fuori vediamo cosa fa la mappa virtuale
a è così noi sì abbiamo ragazzino a me
lo stiamo studiando qualcosa li attirato
un pezzo di carta vedi una pallina di
gatta biglietto cosa si è scritto
ma è scomparso si è scritto che dobbiamo
uscire fuori andare a giocare con i
nostri amici
sicuramente la mamma virtuale ce lo
impedirà un ma che bella casa abbiamo
preso le chiavi per scappare perché la
mamma vittoria
questo livello è stato facilissimo ma i
primi livelli sono sempre più facili
invece perdiamo un po allora è quella
mamma virtuale sta preparando una torta
e la messa in frigo piacciono le torte
di una per i singles white paper che ha
gioco ma che 65 ok ok calmina ero così
arrabbiata ha detto oggi anche un
fascino di torta al cioccolato che siamo
appesi i compiti
bella la nostra camera la nostra camera
e quindi dobbiamo rubare la torta
immagino io ho paura della reazione di
questa mamma verità perché già è
arrabbiata così giochi che bello
sento il rumore del battito quindi volti
le baraccopoli di alcuni della cucina
forza degli brighi che siamo qui
apriamo il frigo prendilo con le mani a
maggio prossimo a livello
mi piace questo tipo ha detto la
prossima volta che vedo quel giocato non
lo butto nella spazzatura perché si
giochi sempre fatto dice beretta torna
con l'elica allora dobbiamo trovare
l'aeroplanino è andare a giocare fuori
ho detto ok ci ha fatto niente perché
non abbiamo ancora prendere
l'aeroplanino come ti chiamo a questo
fuori ma che bel terrazzo fifa mamma
virtuale sta cercando qualcosa ma ora la
regione sta incontrando il panorama
ragazzotto the ocean ho trovati che
prima si è visto non ci ha detto niente
adesso invece se le vostre perfetto
forse perché stavamo cercando di entrare
da dentro dove ha nascosto il nostro
aeroplano siamo tornati in camera sempre
di abusi prima che arrivi la modo
virtuale dove il piano dove l'ha
promesso la nascosto c'è una chiave
preso sei parti questa perché non riesco
a prenderlo credo
ok adesso dobbiamo andare lì senza farsi
beccare dalla mamma virtuale
[Musica]
allora c'è scritto che mamma virtuale a
t ha chiuso dentro a casa così non va in
piscina quindi bisogna trovare un modo
per andare in piscina diamo cosa si urla
adesso c'è allora mamma virtuale sempre
arrabbiata ha detto nostri permetterà di
mettere piede in pc e noi gli abbiamo
risposto alla mamma virtuale che come
facciamo imparare essere dei bravi
nuotatori se non possiamo andare nella
piscina sauna e quindi ora dobbiamo
trovare un modo per andare alla pagina
pentolini senza destare beccati dalla
mamma fosse chiusa mi sembrava troppo
vai qui tornano quindi oltre alla mamma
virtuale se anche il padre virtuale
entrambi mi sembrano molto nervosi sta
facendo la guardia ma anche lui ci urla
contro le non vuole chiusa pò di casa
poverino questo ragazzo finestra aiuto
che paura ci sta cercando ok possiamo
andare a chiave
l'aspetto paura che ha chiuso la porta
di nuovo sta rientrando
forse riusciamo a scappare quando lui e
di alla finestra via allora la porta era
chiusa a chiave abbiamo detto giusto c'è
una finestra e poi da proprio una
piscina
si va a votare in piscina e fino a 20 st
mappa virtuale nei propri caa prossimo
già tascheri bayern bambino spaventoso
noi amiamo halloween e tutte le cose
paurose ma è anche i vampiri e quindi
vediamo gli ho detto se anche a voi
piacciono tantissimo i nostri vediamo
episodio 1 dobbiamo entrare nella casa
di scary vampyr vediamo lacca la casa è
proprio un cappello
eccolo sta uscendo dalla porta lo vedi
sì sì immagino che come iscritti giorno
dobbiamo farci vedere
ok 11 è stato completato subito prossimo
livello facciamo una trappola per il
vampiro
prendi un barile da fuori dalla casa e
metterla e mettilo all'entrata vediamo
ancora barile è abbastanza facile per
ora ma chi come in tutti i giochi primi
livelli sono più facile poi diventata
proprio difficile come iscriviti se lo
abbiamo la telecamera li possiamo vedere
cosa sta parlando con lilli romanelli ma
fuori nel giardino ma si stanno scavando
ok
wow che bella casa ok mettiamo il
secchio qua armando abbiamo scambiamo
capiamo quindi praticamente di sì
persona e secchi messa che verrà da mio
padre di tre figli è bella questo è
l'unico danno chiamati dopo abbiamo una
bella visuale solo chi non vive da eco
sta entrando adesso ha detto l'odio chi
era la mia casa prossimo a scherzo si è
subito che le piace mangiare i biscotti
quindi a me piacciono illustrano i
biscotti con dei biscotti di legno la
pentiti mentre d'oro biscotti di legno
eccoli qua
lui stava dormendo bene ma scusa ma
ghiacciai biscotti di legno vicino alla
porta senza perfetta ma va bene vista 00
al proprio lì su un tavolino a fianco la
sua poltrona
e però poi dopo si possono usare gli
scorsi aiuto scopo stiamo svegliando
si pensi di aver perso un dente i denti
sono molto importanti prima mi diverto
allora dobbiamo mischiare della salsa
piccante nella salsa di sangue che c'è
nella foto la tavola da cucina perché è
stato un bambino è quello che fa è una
buona idea di mettere la salsa piccante
perché sicuramente
vediamo vediamo questa è la cucina ecco
la salsa piccante la prendiamo allora
disse di andare nel tavolo da cucina vai
dritto per la sala da pranzo ciao torna
mai
ok anche a un aborto mattina si sta
arrivando
sta arrivando non mi dire che mi ha già
trovato molto
riproviamoci appreso purtroppo eccoci
qua mettiamo la salsa piccante si abbia
la briga di rho questo è appunto questa
parte sta scendendo le scale adesso devo
stare molto attento dove sa dove andrà
adesso
ok perfetto posso andare di qua allora
non mi vede
sì ecco come sta andando
[Musica]
che paura ha detto a mia bocca ora però
è tutta qui con un bene che votiamo per
il bayern
gli diamo gli do un sei così così non
tanto da halidon stato e mezzo giusto
perché mi piacciono tantissimo i vampiri
a lui e mi piace fare visto che ora
siamo arrivati all'ultimo gioco dovrebbe
anche essere il più pauroso viniamo.it
clown quindi a quanto pare una sorta di
clown spaventoso brasile scream perché
famiglia un po dai ros in campo con il
camioncino come come quello di insomma
se però dove sta andando
[Musica]
mi segue vedere un trucco di magia è un
pendolo e ha ipnotizzato il bambino e
gli ha rubato la bici
non vedo l'ora di aggiungersi alla mia
collezione
ma la bicicletta per dire no ma le mura
che pauroso questo freakclown somigliamo
altra dei scream non fossero mai polonia
dei parte quindi dobbiamo dobbiamo
andare a salvare il bambino
ok dobbiamo salvare ma non so perché ma
ho molta paura ha detto di no sono
anch'io nel furgoncino ma dovevamo
salvarci dovevamo raffiche anche noi no
dove ci stava portando le mans uscire
poi esce dal van dal furgone si di
trovare un punto per nasconderti perché
sta arrivando
ok ci siamo nascosti dietro questi
barili
questo è un benvenuto accanto al mio
caro amico e ancora ipnotizzato il
bambino vedete loro sono entrati là
dentro c'è scritto che dobbiamo trovare
una mappa qua dentro al tra l'altro
abbiamo anche la visione di lui nelle
telecamerine poi vicino alla bici per
vedere la mappa o mi sa che sta
arrivando lui era meglio se ci
nascondiamo e come fai a saperlo
e perché dalle camere si sta venendo
verso di noi
non penso che ci vede qua vero o no no
no no no ma sede sembra nascosti proprio
bene ha detto questo è il mio mondo
tutti seguiranno le mie regole vuole
controllare tutti forse con il pendolo
ipnotizzare tutti ok allora andiamo qui
sulla bicicletta subito ci ha già
scoperto ma dico qui con amici si
potevano mare bene io ok vicino la
bicicletta per aprire la mappa doc canal
plus cuore la scuola
ma attenzione attento contratto vediamo
rientrerei davvero prima esplorerà in
tutto e poi farei e le missioni per
offrire esplorare però dobbiamo salvare
il povero basino che fate ipotizzato ok
io vorrei rimanere
la rai tutta la scuola per meglio se
andiamo salvare il bambino bene stiamo
andando al network che si è dove erano
prima dobbiamo provare ad imparare a 1
accesso negato adoro l'intera arrivando
che cosa vuol dire meno male che non può
che non corre troppo veloce non come
scrive lui ci sta inseguendo il gatto
guarda corsi d'acqua si può entrare non
è anche da questo parte ma come facciamo
ad entrare un ascensore non è anche da
qui cosa dobbiamo fare proviamo vedere
facce così per entrare dentro quartier
generale salvare bambino abbiamo bisogno
dello scotch e dell'impronta digitale
ce la faremo a trovarli ma forse nel
1668 volta che ci ha provato a giriamo
intorno al furgone magari non ci prende
proviamo per vedere se c'è qualcosa qui
allora si sentono le carte
il giornale nella di testa sta arrivando
forse nel lato guidatore dalla parte
davanti non si può entrare di nuovo per
tutto il mondo
mi chiamo si prova si può aprire bravo e
che cosa c'è lì c'è una cosa viola no mi
sa che non c'è niente però c'era un
impronta guarda sul volante no è un
palloncino all impronta però quindi
dobbiamo solo trovare lo scotch
dobbiamo trovare lo scotch sì le
impronte le possiamo prendere dal
volante lui è lì l'ha visto ok siamo
tornati a scuola perché sicuramente lo
scoppio tra tutte queste location
sicuramente ea scuola
proviamo chiamamilano che qua cei
ufficio principale forse quelle luci
servono ad aprire la guarda le
telecamere sì sì anche se non capisco
bene dov'è nonno scappa scappa scappa
scappa dai non mi viene pestato rinaldo
sta entrando qui dalla porta usciamo
dalla finestra noi mettiamo solo
troviamo qui lo scotch
[Musica]
aiuto scappa giusto il tempo arrivando
bottom h
loro sono già scritta miley e lilly
piano riuscire a trovare la combinazione
giusta mi sono sempre devo dire che
questo free clone difficilissimo anche
se è molto molto bello se un pochino più
difficile di ice cream davvero carino
inutile se volete che lo continuiamo la
sua tesi inglese scriveteci nei commenti
se volete che continuiamo primi clown
consegnateci pure altri giochi debole se
ci troviamo e se non avete visto lo
scorso episodio in cui facciamo da baby
sitter alla nipote femmina di prosa
cliccate qua per vederlo se volete
vedere altri giochi di carte e se volete
altri video diversi cliccate in una di
queste due caselline in casa della
carità ciao